so you probably didn't know this but
this program is mostly funded by viewers
like you listeners like you who sign up
for the membership program on our
website we do an extra show every day
for our members i would love for you
to join the membership ranks and you can
do so at joinpacman.com
i want to talk about comedian and actor
russell brand in this segment now i'm
not going to do the lazy he's an
anti-vaccine nut sort of thing that's
been floating around there have been
some articles written that straight up
say russell brand is anti-vaxx i find it
lazy quite frankly
there is a daily beast article called
comedian russell brand has become a
powerful
voice for anti-vaxxers which comes maybe
a little closer to the reality of what's
going on and the way we're going to look
at some clips we're going to look at a
lot of different things the way that i
characterize this is that russell brand
is definitely dancing around on the
topic of vaccination
he's asking questions and making
suggestions all in ways that encourage
vaccine hesitancy or skepticism
without like really explicitly taking an
anti-vaccine position now one can make
the argument
that doing it the way he's doing it
might be more pernicious than straight
up just doing anti-vaxx propaganda i
don't know what his intentions are and
we'll talk about that at the end
we'll look at the material first but
what's clear is that whatever he's been
doing it has worked well to build an
audience
and in particular around these sort of
contrarian ideas as we might call them
and that may play a role in how he's
choosing to frame issues maybe he's
being encouraged to do this stuff
because it's doing well i don't know
let's start with the evolution and we're
going to hit kind of a few different
points and go from there
here is russell brand
um
many times talking about how he is
neutral about everything and just sort
of look into everything
he has no opinion or advice for you
about covet or vaccines or treatments
he's neutral let's take a listen i am
switzerland when it comes to this
subject no view at all i am merely a
floating series of molecules spores in
space that through the spike protein got
attached to something now i'm completely
neutral you can do your own research
into the impact of coronavirus and i
would suggest that you look beyond the
mainstream media into the impact of
vaccines and the efficacy
of vaccines and make your own decisions
i have no opinion i'm not offering any
advice or suggestions or even opinions
around the treatment of kovid just
measuring and
judging the conversation that takes
place around it okay
so
maybe it's good to be neutral sometimes
i guess but the really important
takeaway here is neutrality is not
objectivity neutrality and objectivity
are two different things if i say i'm
neutral between water being necessary
for human life or water being the
biggest scam on earth that humans don't
really need to live
i'm staking out a position of neutrality
but there's nothing objective about it
i'm just completely wrong i'm not
adhering to the facts in my neutrality
i'm neutral but i'm completely wrong so
that's one reason to always be skeptical
about loudly professed neutrality
because neutrality and objectivity are
two different things so let's now look
at russell brand's first statement that
i could find about kovid this was back
in march of 2020 march 13th of 2020 i
believe
this was just a few days after trump
made the big speech about
we're closing this we're closing that
and there's a virus and it's already
sort of like a little bit woo-woo and
starting to this is the type of stuff
that lends itself
to people
looking to you to justify their own
skepticism and disbelief even about
things you're not directly talking about
take a look
my personal take on it is it's a
reminder that reality
lies below the surface the deepest
realities cannot be seen
you know
microbiology can at any point
alter the game and that's what about
what's happening even beneath that held
in fields of invisible energy
so i suppose you know
so it's you know wash your hands yeah be
sensible but significantly remember how
often we live in concepts and constructs
that are not real and are not beneficial
so you know i guess wash your hands but
at the same time you know we can't
really see a lot of this stuff and
i don't know it's starting to get a
little bit squooshy okay
then we cut to this year where it's
really ramped up as his follower base
has grown this type of stuff is ramped
up
this is now we're going from last march
13 to this september 13 just under a
month ago
russell brand says the problem of covid
is small
compared to that of the vaccine mandates
so now we're really getting into some
meaty stuff for the anti-vax crowd
whatever russell's view is of vaccines
per se the problem of coronavirus is
small compared to the problem of the
framework that we are discovering holds
it
a framework of disdain contempt and
conflict as long as we forget
fundamental basic values kindness open
communication tolerance if we forget
those things there is no society worth
saving no matter what you believe now
this is one of those things where like
yeah kindness okay sure sure uh but the
problem of covet is still a big problem
and uh that
this idea of
this this uh minimizing
again whatever his views are it feeds
into it feeds into the people
who want to say we don't need the
vaccine or the mandates are definitely
bad or whatever now here's a little bit
of a break into something that also is
part of this
um russell spoke with tim poole tim
poole is this guy we've interviewed him
before he said he used to be on the left
or he sort of still claims to be 90 of
his content is anti-democratic i've
talked to him about it you know no no it
should not come as a shock to many of
you that um uh he he said he voted for
trump in 2020 so this is another one of
these like i'm sort of i'm on the left
i'm kind of an enlightened centrist
really it just seems that like at least
you're mostly doing content that
criticizes the left and you're voting
for trump okay so russell brings on tim
poole and they do this shtick about
we're very close to civil war very very
close to civil war and this is a trope
now the the the left is ripping us apart
we're they're pushing us to the brink of
civil war you used to say more um
frequently at least as as i'm aware that
you felt that i think i guess in the
final days of trump that america was on
the brink of some kind of civil war and
i still do what do you
yeah there's a uh but there there's been
polling data that i think may uh uh you
know evolve that opinion notably there
was a yougov data that showed i think it
was yougov that uh there's five regions
in the united states there's the
northeastern there's the southern
there's the heartland there's the the
west and the mountain regions
and in each region there was a large
plurality of people who wanted to secede
from the union and form their own
regional governments essentially if you
if you uh normalize for population in
each by each state i did the math you
end up with 37.2 percent of the us
population wanting the country to break
apart okay now i don't exactly know the
normalization he's referring to i know
what normalization means i remember we
talked about that that poll
i don't exactly know i don't know if he
means maybe he doesn't even mean
normalization he just has extrapolated i
think maybe tim doesn't know the
difference between extrapolating and
normalizing
what he's not mentioning is that those
disproportionately wanting to secede or
southern republicans
and
this entire civil war narrative that he
and some others have been pushing
sometimes explicitly sometimes
implicitly i will will grant that it's
not always explicit is
that the left's intolerance or
unwillingness to do whatever is what's
pushing us to the brink of civil war
um the reality is that
you know the closest thing that we got
to a civil war starting that i can
recall in the last many years was the
january sixth insurrection it was
exclusively trump is who did it and even
if you look at secession and secession
and civil war two different things um
it's disproportionately southern
republicans who want to do it and this
is the type of stuff that that russell
platforms i would say it's not
responsible platforming and that he's
not really ready to rebut the substance
of what's being said okay then russell
brand shares a tweet
which seems to be telling people
how to get around covet safety measures
during his comedy tour okay this is
called the 33
tour
russell brand tweeted this and it's 33
tour info and it says
there are some misunderstandings around
the venue requirements for the 33 tour
this should address the concerns we've
seen expressed
no venue requires you to be double
vaccinated so that's sort of like you
can just go and get one and not the
second and you're going to be able to
get in
most venues do not ask for any
certification again saying
it's kind of the honor system at a lot
of places you can probably go without
being vaccinated some require proof of a
negative test and then saying if you
have a ticket that requires you to have
a test and you don't want one we'll move
your ticket to another venue it might
require travel so again it's it's all
kind of slippery like no one of these
things is that egregious but it's all
fomenting a particular line of thought
from the people that follow him okay so
now we'll go to a more recent clip in
this clip russell brand suggests looking
beyond the mainstream media for
information about vaccines and what's
really slippery and squishy about this
one is
i'm the first to agree you can't just
trust corporate media for everything but
the implication here is that there's
this whole other hidden truth that's not
being presented in the corporate media
about vaccines and if you're if you're
aware that the the general narrative
which is accurate is well the vaccines
are quite safe and quite effective
if you're being told there's some other
completely different narrative without
him telling you anything anti-vaxx per
se you start to think wow what what am i
not being told let's take a listen do
your own research into the impact of
coronavirus and i would suggest that you
look beyond the mainstream media into
the impact of vaccines and the efficacy
of vaccines and make your own decisions
i have no opinion right he has no he
still has no opinion but again it's this
idea that you may not be getting told
all the things you should be getting
told and you've got to look for it here
is russell brand then on vaccine
passports which he equates to
totalitarianism
it's very interesting how this
particular issue is being treated with a
very specific and one might argue
totalitarian
mindset where elsewhere our cultures are
built on principles of individualism
like you know well you're an individual
you're responsible for your own life
you're responsible if you're in prison
or if you can't make a go of life
yourself that's your fault that's your
responsibility
so it's being regarded uniquely and as
opposed to someone like me that's
skeptical and sometimes downright
cynical about government the agenda of
governments the relationships of
government with big business
something like this
makes me concerned about the direction
we're heading so again it's just vaguely
alluding to the idea of freedom freedom
is not anybody requiring a vaccine for
sure that that's absolutely not it um
and then this is just where it starts to
get really weird russell says he saw a
dead fish in the river
and that seems like a bad omen from the
standpoint of totalitarian vaccine
passports whatever your views on the
pandemic where it came from how it came
to be here
what the impact of it is on a sort of
individual social and cultural level the
fact is that
now the response to it does align with
some people's opinions about uh
government agenda i.e further control
further invasion
further um
regulation of your life the very idea
that you might not be able to attend a
public event
without
showing a possible that concerns me
other people might say well we've all
got national insurance numbers and stuff
like that
i don't know man i like the other day i
was uh on the river y and i saw dead
fish in that river like you know and
like when you see things that feel like
an indication of something foreboding
it's i think foolish not to respond to
it so that's that's strange okay that
now it starts to get really strange
um and then just to give you kind of
like just a final tour through this here
is russell um saying russiagate quote
russiagate was cooked up by the clintons
which is becoming very popular among the
right the world moves so fast there's
almost no time for history it seems like
years ago that we were hearing that
trump was colluding with russia that he
wouldn't have won the election without
russia that his whole presidency was a
kind of putin plot well there's now
serious evidence that it was the clinton
campaign and hillary clinton acolytes
that were directly involved in the
generation of what has proven to be a
conspiracy untrue think about how much
media you watched so this this is just a
you know
straight-up right-wing talking point and
then lastly
here he says vaccine fact checkers may
not be trustworthy you have to be
open-minded and
open-eyed about the reality of the
information you're being presented
elsewhere in another one of our videos
we talk about the sort of appetite for
apartheid like people have not been
vaccinated should be pushed this way you
know i don't have a strong opinion about
what you should do with your life you
should be free i should be free we
should be free to talk we should be free
to disagree that what i have concerns
about are the legislation and regulation
around the way that information is
communicated information is censored
because i want to feel like i can trust
people i want to feel like i can trust
the media i want to feel like i trust
the government i don't enjoy seeing they
do actually i do enjoy sitting here
doing this but like i feel that the
systems themselves
are so dependent on their own sort of
corrupt
spiraling
interrelationship that it's not possible
for it to operate freely i don't even
think there's anyone evil at facebook or
at cdc or whatever i just think there's
just a big sort of tidal rolling of
profiteering that's so sort of embedded
that people can't see that it's
happening it's bigger than them that's
what a system is a system is like we're
all a set of nodes operating in a
broader trajectory a broader telos and
none of us can sort of like sort of step
outside and go hang on what's going on
is this the best way to do things and if
you can't see a situation like a fact
checker being funded by people who's
chat check facts it's checking it is
quite hard
then then you're not open-minded enough
so anyway even the fact checkers maybe
cannot uh cannot be trusted okay so so
what's the bottom line here the
difficulty here is that this is not like
straight-up anti-vaxx and calling
russell brand anti-vaxx is is lazy it's
not it doesn't really encompass it
there's no real single anti-vaccine clip
he's dancing
he's encouraging anti-vaxx people to
become more anti-vaxx not saying he's
doing it on purpose but he is
um the videos he pumps out all have the
same sort of like tinge which we're
gonna look at
uh problems with the vaccine studies
against the vaccine famous proponent of
the vaccine who you can't trust and he
hints one way while claiming to be
neutral but clearly he's not objective i
mean just we'll we'll look at some of
his uh clip titles here um uh oh the
wuhan lab leak debate just got even
something else
um
uh are the uh wait hold on let's look at
which are the vaccine related ones how
big pharma ceos plan to profit from
keeping you maybe it's sick
can we really trust vaccine fact
checkers
thought biden couldn't sink any lower
think again
vaccine apartheid don lemon's covet
bombshell
uh good science or irresponsible this is
why you can't trust big pharma shocking
wuhan evidence etc it's vaccine mandates
and assault on your bodily uh whatever
it's actually quite similar to the jimmy
dore idea it's very similar to what
jimmy dore does fauci has no answer
study vaccines being administered
incorrectly
vac side effects reported sudden hearing
loss
vaccines cause hurricanes biden says
vaccine customer which is just a muddle
it's just you know that's kind of the
biden dementia story covid surge among
vaccinated it's the exact same type of
idea
um
a couple different things could be
happening one some individuals are just
taking their distress of the
pharmaceutical industry which we should
all have to some degree
and broadly applying it to covid and to
the vaccine in a way that
maybe is well intended but is very much
misguided for others this is a
straight-up grift
i don't know which one it is for russell
brand i i genuinely don't know which
category i put him in taking
pharmaceutical skepticism too far
grift
delusional i don't know but the
evolution of russell brand is giving
significant
uh comfort so to speak and encouragement
to those already skeptical of just going
out and getting vaccinated let me know
what you think it is that's going on
with russell brand